cosmopolitan of las vegas is ready to
help you plan your summertime fun
with their debut poolside entertainment
experiences i hung out with the team
at their new sunset cocktail hour check
it out
so during times like this swimsuit ready
is just
strong right right anna exactly right
strong and sexy this summer so how can
yoga by the pool at the cosmopolitan
help with that
well based on the year that we just had
i think a lot of people just want to get
out and back in
their bodies so that's the purpose of
this glass is to just allow them to
reignite and rejuvenate and even get a
little component of relaxation from
there and stretching
i know for a fact that's what i need so
what kind of yoga can we do
for the sweat 60 summer series
the class style is a combination of yin
and ashtanga okay so
we're building strengthening components
as well as relaxation components and
stretching
is just the natural bridge between the
two okay so
then show me the move and while we do it
explain how people can enroll in your
lovely class all right so
pars votes also known as pyramid so step
one foot forward
one foot back as you fold forward
i'm already feeling this there you go
rest the hands on the blocks very nice
so this class is 25 to register
everybody gets the mat
a water a towel uh-huh and on an inhale
stand up
oh my gosh everybody can just reserve
their spot in advance
on our website the cosmopolitan las
vegas dot com okay awesome
wow i just need to stay in that in that
position for like five minutes straight
and maybe i'll be okay yeah right but
after you do the class obviously there's
more than just that pose within a class
but
after you do a class you can enjoy
brunch
yes and bottomless mostly because what
comes after yoga
champagne and champagne brunch and
champagne they go hand in hand
exactly yeah the overlook grill we have
a brunch so there are breakfast by its
juices
as well as a variety of really delicious
indulgent libations i love it this is so
nice obviously the weather is perfect
out here it's so just so wonderful
to see everyone having fun at the
boulevard pool here at the cosmopolitan
of las vegas
and lastly the cosmopolitanlas vegas.com
is where you can enroll
for june 4th that's right that's when
these classes start the first class
starts june 4th and it'll be happening
the first and third friday of every
month all the way through september 17th
oh my gosh i can't wait i'll be back for
the full class i can't wait
girl this right hamstring i'm ready for
you all right so go to the website to
check out the full schedule of poolside
entertainment here
we've got the cocktail hour we've got
dive in
movies on the big screen and of course
yoga starting june 4th
all right to check out everything